I'm here to talk to you about something
important that may be new to you the
governments of the world are about to
conduct an unintentional experiment on
our climate in 2020 new rules will
require ships to lower their sulphur
emissions by scrubbing their dirty
exhaust or switching to cleaner fuels
for human health this is really good
but sulfur particles in the emission of
ships also have an effect on clouds this
is a satellite image of marine clouds
off the pacific west coast of the United
States the streaks in the clouds are
created by the exhaust from ships ships
missions include both greenhouse gases
which trap heat over long periods of
time and particulates like sulfates that
mix with clouds and temporarily make
them brighter brighter clouds reflect
more sunlight back to space cooling the
climate so in fact humans are currently
running to unintentional experiments on
our climate and the first one were
increasing the concentration of
greenhouse gases and gradually warming
the Earth's system this works something
like a fever in the human body if the
fever remains low its effects are mild
but as the fever rises damage grows more
severe and eventually devastating we're
seeing a little of this now in our other
experiment were planning to remove a
layer of particles that brighten clouds
and shield us from some of this warming
the effect is strongest in ocean clouds
like these and scientists expect the
reduction of sulfur emissions from ships
next year to produce a measurable
increase in global warming bit of a
shocker
in fact most emissions contains sulfates
that brighten clouds cold diesel exhaust
forest fires scientists estimate that
the total cooling effect from emission
particles which they call aerosols when
they're in the climate may be as much as
all of the warming we've experienced up
until now there's a lot of uncertainty
around this the fact
and it's one of the major reasons why we
have difficulty predicting climate but
this is cooling that will lose as
emissions fall so to be clear
humans are currently cooling the planet
by dispersing particles into the
atmosphere at massive scale we just
don't know how much and we're doing it
accidentally that's worrying but it
could mean that we have a fast-acting
way to reduce warming emergency medicine
for our climate fever if you needed it
and it's a medicine with origins in
nature this is a NASA simulation of
Earth's atmosphere showing clouds and
particles moving over the planet the
brightness is the sun's light reflecting
from particles and clouds and this
reflective shield is one of the primary
ways that nature keeps the planet cool
enough for humans and all of the life
that we know in 2015
scientists assess possibilities for
rapidly cooling climate they discounted
things like mirrors in space ping-pong
balls in the ocean icy plastic sheets on
the Arctic and they found that the most
viable approaches involve slightly
increasing this atmospheric fairy
reflectivity in fact it's possible that
reflecting just one or two percent more
sunlight from the atmosphere could
offset two degrees Celsius or more of
warming now I'm a technology executive
not a scientist about a decade ago
concerned about climate I started to
talk with scientists about potential
countermeasures to warming these
conversations grew into collaborations
that became the marine cloud brightening
project which I'll talk about
momentarily and the nonprofit policy
organizations silver lining where I am
today I work with politicians
researchers members of the tech industry
and others to talk about some of these
ideas early on him at British
atmospheric sciences John Latham who
proposed cooling the climate the way
that the ships do but with a natural
source of particles sea salt mists from
sea water sprayed from ships into areas
of sassette
clouds over the ocean the approach
became known by the name I gave it then
marine car brightening early modelling
study has suggested that by deploying
the marine cloud brightening in just 10
to 20 percent of the susceptible ocean
clouds it might be possible to offset as
much as 2 degrees Celsius warming might
even be possible to brighten clouds and
local regions too and reduce the impacts
caused by warming ocean surface
temperatures for example regions such as
the Gulf Atlantic might be cooled in the
months before hurricane season to reduce
the force of storms or it might be
possible to cool waters flowing onto
coral reefs overwhelmed by heat stress
like Australia's Great Barrier Reef but
these ideas are only theoretical and
bright be marine clouds is not the only
way to increase the reflection of the
sunlight from the atmosphere another
occurs when large volcanoes release
material with the nuts enough force to
reach the upper layer of the atmosphere
the stratosphere when Mount Pinatubo
erupted in 1991 it released material
into the stratosphere including sulfates
that mix with the atmosphere to reflect
sunlight this material remained and
circulated around the planet it was
enough to cool the climate by over half
the degrees Celsius for about two years
his cooling led to a striking increase
in Arctic ice cover in in 1992 which
dropped in subsequent years as the
particles fell back to earth but the
volcanic phenomenon led Nobel Prize
winner Paul Crutzen
to propose the idea that dispersing
particles into the stratosphere in a
controlled way might be a way to counter
global warming now this has risk that we
don't understand including things like
heating up the stratosphere or damage to
the ozone layer scientists think that
there could be safe approaches to this
but is this really where we are this
really really worth considering this is
a simulation from the US National Center
for Atmospheric Research global climate
model showing Earth's surface
temperatures through 2100 the globe on
the Left visualizes
current trajectory and on the right a
world where particles are introduced in
the stratosphere gradually in 2020 in
the Atene through through 2100
intervention keeps surface temperatures
near those of today well without it
temperatures rise well over three
degrees this could be the difference
between a safe and an unsafe world so if
there's even a chance that this could be
close to reality is something we should
consider seriously today there are no
capabilities and scientific knowledge is
extremely limited we don't know whether
these inventions whether these types of
interventions are even feasible or how
to characterize their risks researchers
hope to explore some basic questions
that might help us know whether or not
these might be real options or whether
we should rule them out it requires
multiple ways of studying the climate
system including computer models to
forecast changes analytic techniques
like machine learning and many types of
observations and though its
controversial it's also critical that
researchers develop core technologies
and perform small-scale real-world
experiments there are two research
programs proposing experiments like this
at Harvard the scope acts experiment
would release very small amounts of
sulfates cussin carbonate and water into
the stratosphere with a balloon to study
chemistry and and physics effects how
much material less than the amount
released in one minute of light from a
commercial aircraft so this is
definitely not dangerous and it may not
even be scary at the University of
Washington scientists hope to spray a
fine mist of salt water into clouds in a
series of land and ocean tests if those
are successful this will culminate an
experiment to measurably brighten an
area of clouds over the ocean submarine
cloud brightening effort is the first to
develop any technology for generating
aerosols for atmospheric sunlight
reflection in this way
it requires producing very tiny
particles
think about what comes out of the the
mist that comes out of an asthma inhaler
at massive scale so think of looking up
at a cloud it's a it's a tricky
engineering problem so this one nozzle
they develop generates three trillion
particles per second 80 nanometers and
size from very corrosive salt water it
was developed by a team of retired
engineers in Silicon Valley here they
are working full-time for six years
without pay for their grandchildren it
will take a few million dollars and
another year or two to develop the full
spray system they need to do these
experiments in other parts of the world
research efforts are emerging including
small modeling programs at Beijing
Normal University in China the Indian
Institute of Science a proposed Center
for climate repair at Cambridge
University in the UK and the decimals
fund which sponsors researchers in
global South countries to study the
potential impacts of these sunlight
interventions in their part of the world
but all of these programs including the
experimental ones lack significant
funding in understanding these
interventions is a hard problem the
earth is a vast complex system and we
need major investments in climate models
observations and basic science to be
able to predict climate much better than
we can today and manage both our
accidental and any intentional
interventions and it could be urgent
recent scientific reports predict that
in the next few decades
fever is on a path to devastation
extreme heat and fires major loss of
ocean life collapse of Arctic ice
displacement and suffering for hundreds
of millions of people the fever could
even reach tipping points where warming
takes over in human efforts are no
longer enough to counter accelerating
changes in natural systems to prevent
this circumstance the UN's International
Panel on Climate Change predicts that we
need to stop and even reverse emissions
by 2050 how we have to quickly and
radically
transform major economic sectors
including energy construction
agriculture or transportation than
others and it is imperative that we do
this as fast as we can but our fever is
now so high the climate experts say we
also have to remove massive quantity as
you co2 from the atmosphere possibly ten
times all of the world's annual
emissions in ways that aren't proven yet
right now we have slow moving solutions
to a fast-moving problem even with the
most optimistic assumptions our exposure
to risk in the next 10 to 30 years is
unacceptably high in my opinion could
interventions like these provide
fast-acting medicine if we need it to
reduce the Earth's fever while we
address this underlying causes there are
real concerns about this idea some
people are very worried that even
researching these interventions could
try to provide an excuse to delay
efforts to reduce emissions this is also
known as a moral hazard but like most
medicines interventions are more
dangerous more that you do so research
actually tends to dry out the fact that
we absolutely positively cannot continue
to fill up the atmosphere with
greenhouse gases that these kinds of
alternatives are risky and if we if we
were to use them we need to use as
little as possible but even so could we
ever learn enough about these
interventions to manage the risk who
would make decisions about when and how
its intervene what if some people are
worse off or they just think they are
these are really hard problems but what
really worries me is that if climate
impacts worsen leaders will be called on
to respond by any means available I for
one don't want them to act without real
information and much better options
scientists think it will take a decade
of research just to assess these
interventions before we ever were to
develop or use them yet today the global
level of investment in these
interventions is effectively zero so
we need to move quickly if you want
policymakers to have real information on
this kind of emergency medicine there is
hope the world has solved these kind of
problems before in the 1970s we
identified an existential threat to our
protective ozone layer in the 1980s
scientists politicians and industry came
together in a solution to replace the
chemicals causing the problem they
achieved this with the only legally
binding environmental agreements signed
by all countries in the world the
Montreal Protocol still enforced today
it has resulted in a recovery of the
ozone layer and is the most successful
environmental protection effort in human
history we have a far greater threat now
but we do have the ability to develop
and agree on solutions to protect people
and restore our climate to health this
could mean that to remain safe we
reflect sunlight for a few decades while
we clean our industries and remove co2
it definitely means we must work now to
understand our options for this kind of
emergency medicine thank you
[Applause]
[Music]